[Music]  booker  two bodies around and gets the shot off  the max  [Applause]  [ __ ]  ability to elevate lock and load on the  rim  that's beautiful and people will say  about mid-range shots in today's game  [ __ ] pulls up puts it in  getting into the seams forcing help and  delivering the basketball  to aiden bahamas is happy rondo hands it  off to jackson jackson sees an opening  throws it away here comes bridges  bridges to booker back to bridges  and he does it in the western conference  finals  36 points 12 rebounds  they were down by 10 with under two  minutes to go in this game  the clip is aggressive booker has a  layup but he throws it down  40 points